netflix à lui tout seul utilise 13 % de
la bande passante mondial sur internet
netflix est une absolue catastrophe pour
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
[Musique]
ce qu'on appelle la pollution numérique
en fait c'est toutes les formes de
pollution qui sont liées au fait qu'on
ait un système numérique
en ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre liées au système
numérique
aujourd'hui ça représente la même chose
que la totalité des camions qui
circulent dans le monde et ça augmente
de 10 % par an à côté de ça on a
d'autres pollutions notamment les
pollutions liées à l'activité minière et
à l'extraction d'hydrocarbures à l'amour
on a entre 40 et 60 métaux différents
dans un smartphone ou un ordinateur donc
ça veut dire que 40 ou 60 fois il a
fallu aller les faire des trous dans la
terre un peu partout racines et les
métaux de la métallurgie est tous assez
de l'industrie qui toujours fera de la
pollution le fonctionnement des
datacenters et 20% du total
la fabrication de tous les terminaux
qu'on utilise des ordinateurs les
smartphones et des éléments de réseau
c'est à peu près la moitié et le
fonctionnement des terminaux qu'on
utilise c'est à peu près un tiers la
vidéo aujourd'hui utilisent 80% de la
bande passante internet netflix à lui
tout seul
utilise 13 % de la bande passante
mondial donc netflix est une absolue
catastrophe pour les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
[Musique]
la première chose très utile qu'on peut
faire c'est sinon arrêtez de regarder
des vidéos donc vous pouvez très bien à
partir de maintenant tourner le bouton
ne plus m'écouter
mais sinon c'est de mettre la définition
le plus bas possible parce que plus la
définition est haute et plus on a besoin
de faire circuler une grande quantité
d'informations pour que la vidéo puisse
s'afficher correctement après la
deuxième chose qu'on peut faire c'est de
pas ont regardé trop on peut éviter
d'envoyer la vidéo du petit dernier à la
terre entière qui en général s'en fiche
si on a un abonnement des flics sont
peut le résilier
ça c'est quelque chose qui est également
de la sobriété numérique
si on se dit je n'imite pas mésusage
donc après un écran j'achète un plus
grand écran et après avoir un écran dans
la maison j'en mets deux puis trois puis
quatre et après avoir un smartphone j'en
ai 2 etc
on peut demander aux ingénieurs de faire
des prouesses jamais ils rattraperont la
vitesse à laquelle les usages augmente
si on veut limiter la pollution
numérique il n'ya qu'une seule chose à
faire c'est limiter les usages dont dire
non le collier du chien connectés j'en
ai pas besoin il la montre
connectez j'en ai pas besoin et le frigo
connectés j'en ai pas besoin on devrait
ne pas faire le déploiement de la scène
j'aime ça c'est une réglementation ça ne
dépend que des plus que de la puissance
publique de dire on ne fera pas la
changer ou bien on ne fera pas la
voiture autonome qui est probablement en
termes de débits de données quelque
chose qui n'est absolument pas
compatible avec la sobriété numérique
[Musique]